subscription payments are one of the
most effective ways to monetize your
software in this episode we're going to
use the stripe payments API along with
angular firebase and cloud functions to
build a subscription model into an app
by the end of this video you'll be able
to accept credit cards through your
front-end angular app and then save
information about the subscription in
the firebase database and handle
recurring payments with stripe web hooks
I have to warn you that this video
covers a lot of code in a very short
amount of time so I recommend going to
angular firebase comm to follow along
with the source code and get additional
content related to stripe payments so
first things first you'll need to have a
stripe account which you can get at
stripe com then retrieve your test API
key and add it to your environment TS
file and angular then we're going to add
the stripe Checkout j/s library to the
index.html file it goes in the head tag
and it allows us to collect credit card
details then send them back to stripe
then the last thing we need to do is
tell typescript about stripe so we go to
the Taipings DTS file and then just
declare a variable called striped
checkout from here we'll initialize
cloud functions in our project using the
firebase CLI so we ran firebase and knit
functions from there we also need to set
our stripe test key in the functions
environment so we can do that by running
firebase functions config set stripe
test key with your test key in there
then we'll CD into the functions
directory and install the stripe NPM
package we do that with NPM installs
stripe save and this allows us to
communicate with the stripe API from our
node.js cloud functions environment ok
so that wraps up the initial setup now
we can actually start building this
subscription model before we can create
a subscription we need to create a
customer and stripe it's easiest if you
create that customer as soon as your
user signs up for your app so we're
going to create a cloud function that
runs as soon as a user signs up for the
first time and it's going to save the
stripe customer ID in this customers
node on the database the stripe customer
ID will be the key and the firebase user
ID will be the value this data structure
is going to come into play later when we
start using web hooks to handle
recurring payments and we're also going
to duplicate this data on the user
checked itself so you can see here under
the user ID we have the customer ID as
well if you're lost at this point make
sure to check out some of my videos
covering user authentication with
firebase now we're going to jump into
the functions index.js file and build
this first cloud function so first we're
going to initialize the function with
the admin database then we'll initialize
the stripe library with the API key that
we had configured in the environment
earlier then we're going to call this
function create striped customer and
it's going to run whenever a new user
signs up firebase has a built in auth
trigger called oncreate that will run
this function whenever a new user signs
up when it runs it's going to give us
access to this event variable which just
contains that user off data then we're
going to return a stripe promise by
calling stripe customers create and then
to create a customer all I have to do is
pass it an email address then once that
promise resolves with stripe it's going
to return a customer object and what we
want to do with this customer object is
save it in the firebase database but we
have two different locations to save it
at so we're going to create an updates
object here and first we're going to
save the user ID on the customers node
then we'll do the inverse of that by
saving that customer ID on the user's
node we structure the update like this
so it either succeeds or fails together
this is known as an atomic update or
fan-out in firebase so to make the
update we just reference the root
database and pass at this updates object
from here you can deploy the function
and then go test it out by signing up a
new user and you should see that
customers node and the user node be
updated with the corresponding data now
that we have that done I'm going to
create a service that will save the
payment token to firebase when the user
enters their credit card details so
first we're going to need the
angularfire database and angularfire
off services and then we're also going
to imports which map and do from rxjs
then I'm going to set a variable for the
current users ID and also a observable
of their membership status in the
database to get the membership status we
first need to call the angular fire off
State observable and then once we have
that we're just going to set the
user ID on the service itself and then
we'll call switch map and use the users
ID to retrieve their membership in the
database so we can do that by calling
object users user ID and then we're
going to save it under the pro
membership eventually the pro membership
node will have the current status of
their membership as well as the next
payment date when a user enters their
credit card details through striped
checkout it will send us back a payment
token we need to save this payment token
in the firebase database and then
trigger a cloud function whenever it's
updated so for now we'll just save it
directly under the pro membership under
that users ID okay now we can create a
component that will be responsible for
collecting the user's credit card
information first we will import the
payment service that we just created and
then we'll go ahead and import our
environment variables which have the
stripe API key then we'll create a
variable for that handler and inject the
payment service and the constructor and
we'll configure the handle ordering ng
on a net and we can do that by calling
stripe checkout configure then pass it
an object of different configuration
options the important thing is the key
which is the stripe API key then token
which takes a callback function after
stripe sends us the token back once we
have that token we can use our payment
service to save it to the firebase
database now that we have it configured
we just need an event handler that
allows the user to open it so we can
call this handler open and then pass a
few variables here which describe what
they're paying for in this case it's a
pro subscription and the amount is 1500
which translates to 15 u.s. dollars in
this case in the component HTML we can
reference the payment membership
observable and we'll set that as a
template variable called pro in this
case if the pro status is not active
then we want to go ahead and show the
payment button then when the user clicks
that button it will open the stripe
event handler and then what we're in
here will check and see if the user has
an active membership and if so we'll
just show a div here showing that the
subscription is active this is a very
simplistic approach
in the real world you probably want to
show a payment history as well as an
option to cancel and other little
convenience features like that
so now we'll enter some card details and
we're just using a test credit card from
stripe once the payment completes we
should see that token being saved here
under the pro membership under that
users account so it looks like that's
working fine now we just need a another
cloud function to build the subscription
once this event happens to do that go
over to your stripe account dashboard
and make sure you're viewing the test
data then go to subscriptions and plans
and we're just going to create it
manually although I should note you can
create these plans programmatically
which is especially useful if your users
can customize their own plans now we can
jump back to the index.js file and
create a cloud function that will add a
customer to this subscription plan the
function name will be create
subscription then we'll run the function
whenever the users user ID pro
membership token is updated so that will
happen when the user enters their card
detail and we want to build the
subscription and charge the customer
this is going to give us an event
variable which we can use to retrieve
the token value that we've already saved
to the database in this case we can get
the token value by calling event data
Val then we'll also save that user ID as
a variable here and we can throw an
error if any of this essential data is
missing okay the next step is to query
the admin database for the actual user
data so we reference users user ID pull
that value once and then have the
snapshot resolved into a promise and
once we have that data back from
firebase we can call stripe
subscriptions create which we need to
provide a stripe customer ID as well as
a source for the payment which in most
cases would be a credit card in our case
we saved the customer ID when the user
first signed up and we saved the credit
card token ID in the last step when you
create a subscription you have an array
of items so in our case we're just gonna
add the pro membership item but you
could also add like a setup fee or any
customized options you want here as well
this is going to return a promise and on
stripes end they're going to create a
subscription and also charge the
customer if the charge fails it will
raise an error
so once we get the subscription back we
can go ahead and reference the users pro
membership and firebase and then we'll
just go ahead and update it to active
but there's all kinds of additional data
you could save here if you wanted to and
the final step will be to catch any
errors and that should be it for our
subscription cloud function you can go
ahead and deploy it and then if you go
charge the card again you should see the
pro membership updated and then the
subscription turn to active so if we
look at the object it has a status of
active as well as our token that we
saved there before and we can also go
into stripe and we should be able to see
the subscription saved there as well so
going into the stripe dashboard we can
see this user is subscribed to the pro
membership and then we have a history of
their payments and any other activity
here as well so that's pretty cool but
there's still one more piece to the
puzzle that we still haven't solved and
that's handling recurring payments as
they happen asynchronously once a month
stripe uses web hooks as a way to send
data to your app so once a month they're
going to charge the users card and then
they'll send the data to a web hook that
you provide a web hook is just a URL
where you can receive the data and then
run some code and response to it we can
handle this with firebase HTTP cloud
functions the end result is going to
look like this we'll send a test payment
failed web hook and then it's going to
update the users pro membership to pass
too and then if we get a payment
succeeded web hook it updates it back to
active let's go back to index j/s and
create the cloud function that will
handle this logic let's give the
function a name of recurring payment and
we'll make it an HTTP function which is
going to return a request and a response
so first with the request we need to get
the request body type as well as the
request body data object and that's just
the data that is being sent to us from
stripe it has things like the customers
customer ID as well as the subscription
status and we'll go ahead and throw an
error if any of this data is missing
then stripe is not going to send us the
firebase user ID but it is going to send
us the stripe customer ID that's why we
saved it on its own customer node that
points to the firebase user ID so we can
reference that customer ID and then with
that data we can update
the data on the actual firebase user ID
so once we get the user ID we'll make a
reference to that point in the database
and there's two possible hooks here we
can either have a payment succeeded or a
payment failed so we'll just use a
conditional if statement and if the
invoice payment succeeded then we'll
just go ahead and update the status to
active and then likewise if the payments
failed then we'll go ahead and update
the status to past due this is a pretty
simplistic approach and stripe sends all
kinds of other web hooks that you can
listen for so check out the docs to see
the full customization options now the
last thing we need to do is send a
response back to stripe if we send a 200
response that means we received it and
we updated the database and everything
is good to go we can also send a 300 or
400 level response which stripe we'll
treat as an unsuccessful request and in
that case stripe will try to retry the
webhook a certain number of times you
can configure the retry attempts in the
stripe dashboard go ahead and deploy the
function but this time make note of the
URL that it returns from you for this
recurring payment function from the
stripe dashboard you'll want to go to
API and then web hooks and then add an
endpoint you can just copy and paste
this URL directly in the endpoint and
then we're gonna go down here and select
the invoice payment succeeded and
invoice payment failed options then
click Add endpoint and stripe will start
sending web hooks to that address now
when we start testing this web hook
stripes going to send it to a customer
with all zeros so we're gonna go in the
firebase database and just point that
test customer to our current user that
we're working with from here you can
click on test web hook from the stripe
dashboard and choose the type of request
you want to send so in this case we'll
first send a payment failed request and
you can see that changes the status to
past due and we can do the same thing
for payment succeeded and we should see
the status updated back to active if you
get any errors at this point it's always
a good idea to look at the firebase
function logs and you can see exactly
what kind of error is happening inside
your function
so that's just barely scratching the
surface of the possibilities of stripe
subscription payments if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you want to talk about building your
own custom subscription system consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase com you'll get a free copy of
my book as well as one on one project
consulting thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]